salut à tous aujourd'hui petite vidéo de
pêche éléments dont on comprend à la
suite de la vidéo petits pains riche en
trouvailles
voilà on retourne finir le port de paul
je pense qu'on aura pas mal de trucs
avait du tout il y avait des pièces y
avait des plaques d'immatriculation et
avaient des objets des pieux de péniches
donc on leur enverra je pense que je
pense que ça va être une bonne saison de
pêche
[Musique]
je lis portion de canal c'est un peu
dégagé il ya un poisson péniche en
dehors du pot je lance et je crois que
c'est quelque chose
c'est lourd
plus aucune barre
non c'est beau rigole ça fait du poids
en tout cas
oh non une grosse pile
ça c'est abusé dans l'eau c'est terrible
ça dans lost terrible ça ça rien à faire
dans l'eau
scandale c'est scandaleux de jeter à
l'eau
oh qu'est ce donc
parce que c'est ça est ce que ce serait
pas un disque dur est ce que ce serait
pas un disque dur semble rien le petit
si c'est les patrons alors les traits
d'un plastique et tout en laissant mais
là c'est une couche pour adultes alors
on va la laisser
mais c'est de la merde
[Musique]
je vais vous les âges et les grands pas
mal
donc là la péniche avant de partir donc
on va tester on peut trouver
on a peut-être payé l'essence avec le
faire
encore un morceau ordinateur parce que
un cache peut-être un ordinateur dans le
cam
au sortir d'un coup trois couteaux une
faute de cigarettes et à mettre un tout
à l'heure j'ai caudal ouais j'aurais
essayé la pop trois mêmes ouais bah ce
qui est dedans mais je pense qu'il
reviendra de la merde et le maître chez
frost qui vaut 3 les mêmes - aurait
essayé
à hilla utilisable non
a été donné pour habiller peut-être un
peu
je sais pas si ce n'était pas au bord
tous à temps vers la sellerie c'est le
risque qui se remplit pas bien non
et wall e
et puis regarde c'est juste là rien et
même leur en papier d'emballage ice aura
découvert neuf fond de l'eau il devait
être un peu dégoûté ce qu'ils ont perdu
3 pas dû le déplier mexes à l'avant à
nettoyer
tu te le dire aux oyats ce petit
tournevis petit tournevis plat en garde
aucun j'ai perdu ma corde s'est défait
j'ai perdu ma corde dans les gradins
[ __ ] il s'est défait s'est défait de
ma demande du tour de ma taille [ __ ]
heureusement la flotte
ça revient toujours ils sont bien
passées alors hein
a encore quelque chose moi oh il est
beau il est beau il est beau aussi là
tout en plastique un de plus dans la
collection
ça c'est peut-être un vieux couteau on
dirait un vieux couteau il a bien morflé
à une pièce où elle est belle oya la
reine d'angleterre sur ma pièce 2013
temp un lot
le mec il a une caméra sur sa péniche
qui va voir passer des aimants ont
failli au niveau de ce pont on n'est pas
déçus du voyage
parce que c'est un sac de pièces un sac
de pièces tout simplement
c est montrer parce que beaucoup de 1 et
de 2 506 vie à beaucoup de 5 centimes
donc cémenté léger aussi quelques pièces
jaunes donc ça ça fait toujours
extrêmement plaisir vaut quand même
c'est 20 centimes
parce que de tout est en parfait état
donc voilà empêche de l'argent ça fait
plaisir
ah bah ouais ça va un petit sac d'argent
brad et kate rouge mais bon c'est ça
j'ai l'impression que ça a déjà été fait
mais bon bref déjà vu voix ils ont
essayé des trucs alors comme bah ouais
ici va pas du coup je vais saisir au
même endroit ouais moi ça c'est
peut-être les cambriolages quand ils
chopent les caisses ils veulent pas se
faire chier ouais les pièces rouges ils
sont bâchées en fait oui c'est quand
même alors peut-être cigarettes sait
jamais ce cap dans mais bon non halal
alors vide ouais t'as rien si cette
vidéo vous a plu n'hésitez pas à vous
abonner à laisser un petit live
voir bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
[Musique]